[Music]
rapunzel is probably one of the best
Disney Princesses ever but will you like
her as much once you know what really
happened to her stay tuned until the end
to know how her fairy tale ended if you
love Disney Princesses as much as we do
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up today we
are showing you the disturbing real
story behind Disney's Tangled the
beginning once upon a time there was a
man and a woman who always wished to
have a child but every attempt failed
then one day the woman was looking
through the window and saw a garden
filled with the most beautiful herbs and
flowers
it belonged to a witch with great power
who was feared by everyone so no one
dared to enter there but when the woman
saw some Rapunzel in the garden she
wanted them so badly that she became
miserably ill this was when she asked
her husband it gets him Rapunzel from
the garden or she would die and he loved
her so much that he decided to do it no
matter the cost this is why he climbed
over the high hall and the sorceress his
garden to steal the Rapunzel his wife
ate it and asked for more but the second
time he went into the garden the man got
caught by the witch this is why she
asked her the first child that his wife
would bring to the world and she would
take care of it like a mother the man
agreed and this is how the little
Rapunzel was adopted by the witch but
instead of treating her like her own
child she locked her in a tower with
only a little window when she was 12
years old whenever she wanted to see her
she just had to ask her puzzle to let
down her hair and she climbed up the
Prince Rapunzel was feeling really
lonely in her tower that was until a
prince was riding through the forest he
heard the beautiful voice of the young
woman who was singing in her tower
unfortunately he couldn't find any way
to climb up the tower he came back
another day and saw the witch climbing
up her hair this is why he had the idea
to pretend that he was the wish asked
Rapunzel to let down her hair and
climbed up the young woman had never
seen a man before and she was terrified
but then he began talking to her in a
friendly manner and she lost her fear he
immediately asked her she would take him
as her husband and she immediately said
yes however she didn't know how to get
down this is why she asked him to bring
a strand of silk every time he would
come to the tower
this way she would be able to weave a
ladder and she would climb down when it
would be finished then he would have a
chance to take her on his horse this is
why they made sure that they would be
able to see each other every evening to
make sure that the witch wouldn't see
him during the
however their fairy tale ended when the
young Rapunzel made one big mistake the
pregnancy in the latest version of the
story Rapunzel was simply dumb enough to
ask a really stupid question
out of nowhere she asked the witch why
it was more difficult to pull her up
compared to the young prince who will be
arriving any moment now
but another version of the story is a
little less appropriate for children
when you know that the prince didn't
mind climbing up Rapunzel's hair every
night he probably guessed that his
intention was not only to bring her a
strand of silk after all it would have
been easier to simply bring a ladder and
the couple would have been able to run
away together but the prince was really
interested in being in her room every
night and you know what this can lead to
the young woman innocently asked the
witch why her waistband was getting
bigger this is when the witch understood
that the young Rapunzel was pregnant the
couple had been having fun before
marriage and the Prince never told her
that she could get pregnant from this
this was when the witch understood that
she had been seeing a man during all
this time even though she had tried to
remove her from the world then the witch
decided to punish her and this is not
something that any kid would like to see
the tragedy when she found out that
Rapunzel had been betraying her during
all this time she decided to cut off her
hair then she took the pregnant young
woman into the wilderness where she
suffered greatly on the same day the
witch decided to stay in a tower and
tied the cut off hair to the hook at the
top of the tower by the way that means
that Rapunzel would have been able to
escape on her own if she cut her hair
but she also told the witch about her
prince so she was probably not that
smart after spending so many years alone
in a tower anyway the Prince asked
Rapunzel to let down her hair and this
was when the witch sled down the cut off
hair to trick him the Prince climbed up
the tower and this was when he found the
witch she was waiting for him she told
him you have come for your mistress
darling but that beautiful bird is no
longer sitting in her nest nor is she
singing anymore the cat got her and will
scratch your eyes out as well
you have lost Rapunzel you will never
see her again the prince was overcome
with grief and he threw himself from the
tower he survived but fell into thorns
that poked out his eyes the end that
couldn't be a fairy tale without a happy
ending but unfortunately it wasn't as
good as it seems the prince had become
blind and he wandered around in the
forest eating nothing but grass and
roots but the most terrible thing was
probably that he lost the love of his
life that was until he finally found the
place where Rapunzel has been living
with the twins she had given
- that means that she had given birth
alone in the wilderness even though she
didn't even know what pregnancy was the
Prince heard a voice that sounded
familiar he approached it and this is
when Rapunzel finally recognized him the
young woman then threw her arms around
his neck crying two of her tears fell
into his eyes and the prince wasn't
blind anymore this was when he was able
to lead her into his kingdom where he
and his new family were received with
joy in another version of the story
Rapunzel had to live alone in the desert
which makes things worse
but both stories had the same happy
ending the young couple then lived
happily ever after with their two kids
which story do you prefer the original
tale or the Disney movie don't be shy to
answer in the comments section down
below we love to hear what you think and
that's it for the disturbing real story
behind Disney's Tangled if you liked
this video don't forget to subscribe and
please give us a big thumbs up thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]